The answer is none of these work.
He couldn't generate them himself because if he generated them himself,
there's no way Alice could generate these garbled tables.
He can ask Alice to provide them. That would require him to reveal his input.
And the whole point of this protocol is for him not to have to do that.
This approach wouldn't work either--if Alice gives Bob both of the values for each input,
then he can evaluate these gates with both of these values,
and he will learn more about Alice's inputs than he should.
The answer is none of these work. We need some other solution.
We need some way to enable Bob to obtain these inputs
without revealing to Alice what Bob's actual values are.